cie
diese begeisterten rundum perfektes
cooles neues
15 von 10 möglichen punkten leute
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein
richtiges hasen pinto ist gut wir machen
erdbeer tacos bzw cheese cake oder noch
besser auf irgendetwas besser als
strawberry cheesecake tacos ich starte
direkt habe richtig bock auf dieses
rezept ich werde euch alles ganz genau
hier unten in die infobox schreiben wie
immer startet mit den keksen dann nehmt
ihr euch einfach für die ta cco schaltet
erst mal butterkekse die müssen wir auf
einmal ihr können halt ganz normale
butterkeksen nehmen ihr könnt aber auch
diese karamell spekulatius kekse nehme
ich mache halt einfach beide varianten
es wird erstmal wirklich wie so eine art
wie das von mir von den keks boden kennt
dass wir erst noch mit geschmolzener
butter gleiche verbinden aber das zeige
ich euch gleich nur dann haben wir das
schön fein gemixt und dann geht's weiter
[Musik]
als nächstes brauchen wir ja es gibt ja
die ganz großen und es gibt halt auch
kleine das sind die kleinsten die ich
gefunden habe die sind aber immer noch
zu groß daher nehme ich mir hier einfach
so eine kleine schüssel und wehrt die
dann nochmal ausschneiden weil es so
groß brauchen wir die nicht den rest
werden wir natürlich verwerten daraus
mache ich gleich was cool ist das zeige
ich euch schon zum schluss oder
vielleicht fühle mich als tik tok video
ab und hängen ist euch dran hat sie mir
aber auf tik tok und aufgaben nicht volk
dann solltet ihr das nicht tun da könnt
ihr auch vollauf mitbestimmen was hier
so als nähe ist das online gehen und
dann kriegt ihr halt immer auch ganz
viele andere sachen mit soll ich gucke
gerade kann der größe her ja es ist so
echt optimal weil das wird gleich noch
gepflegt da hat man so ja so ein
bisschen finde ich cool ich mach das
jetzt erstmal weiter dann kommen nämlich
eine coole party
[Musik]
die tortillas sind jetzt vorbereitet ihr
könnt natürlich auch immer mehrere
übereinander stapeln und dann schneiden
da braucht er natürlich ein scharfes
messer und mutter habe ich schon
verlassen in der mikrowelle bei
geringerer wattzahl sonst platzt die
euch sondern ärgert er schon oft
passiert
und jetzt machen wir verfolgen ist wir
nehmen uns einen pinsel und pinseln dann
beide seiten von unserem tortilla und
dann könnte ja überlegen verkehrs mit
dem butterkeksen an oder mit den anderen
keksen ich mache jetzt erstmal ein blech
mit den butterkeksen da habe ich mir
auch schon mein muffin blech hierher
geholt weil das hilft damit das einfach
schön stehen kann und wir brauchen diese
besondere formen und jetzt einfach hier
umwälzen von beiden seiten
und dann hier einfach in der muffin form
umgedreht einmal aufstellen und dann
könnt ihr immer drei pro linie machen
ich mache zwei bleche also sechs quasi
mit dem butterkeksen 6 und den karamell
keks und den backofen habe ich auch
schon vorgeheizt aber die backzeit
verrate ich euch gleich nochmal
[Musik]
das ist die creme fraiche sauce mit salz
und pfeffer und so
der arme bringt es ein süßer tag aber
ist auch ein gutes leben zu machen gut
wir machen jetzt dass die der das
ja dann anwesenheit verwirrt mich also
wir machen jetzt das schiff
so will man jetzt das cheesecake die
cheesecake füllung meine güte also ich
habe jetzt hier doppel ram frischkäse
damit jetzt philadelphia genommen ich
finde das schmeckt wenn man das auch
nicht verpackt auch immer sehr neutral
dann kommt da für die süße puderzucker
dazu dass sie mich jetzt einfach und
dann natürlich niemals ohne vanille
extrakt schließlich ohne extra kann und
was auch nie fehlen darf neben dem
vanille extrakt perfektes pondorf sind
ist was haben deutsch heute ist zitrone
entweder nimmt ihr einfach nur ein
bisschen zitronensaft oder wenn ihr eine
bio zitrone habt gerne auch den schein
ab rief da nimmt ihr euch eine feine
reihe und dürfen niemals das weiße was
unter der gelben schale ist was sich
darunter befindet dürfte niemals mit
rein rein weil das ist bitter dass
wirklich nur das gelbe abreiben bisschen
vom saft und dann rühren wir es für 10
sekunden um
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt noch schlag sahne
steif geschlagen zusammen mit etwas
sahne fest und vor lauter verwirrung
gegen hamm sah habe ich vergessen noch
ein bisschen zitronensaft mit
reinzubringen
ich finde es gibt halt noch mal so einen
frischekick
und dann müssen wir eigentlich nur noch
mit einem teich aber ihr kennt ihr das
spielchen einfach nur noch die sahne
unter die mascarpone masse heben und das
mit ganz viel liebe damit ganz viel luft
auch drin bleiben die macht schön luftig
wird und sobald wir das haben und unsere
tacos abgekühlt sind können wir auch
noch füllen beziehungsweise könnte in
der zwischenzeit eigentlich auch die
erdbeeren hast du schon mal vorbereiten
bei den tacos habe ich übrigens noch ein
tipp ich habe sie schon gesehen wir sind
ja fertig und da könnt ihr wirklich nur
nach dem backen so lange sie noch warm
sind ein bisschen was eine form
verändern und ich habe es jetzt auch in
so einer baguette form hingelegt das
hilft einfach dabei ist dass man die
frauen bei welt wenn er das nicht habt
dann könnt ihr das noch in der nacht
vorm auskühlen lassen aber so sieht
einfach schicker aus
[Musik]
für unser erdbeer topping werden jetzt
die erdbeeren einfach nur richtig schön
fein geschnitten wir sind auch so ein
bisschen weicher geworden ist aber in
dem fall gar nicht schlimm münchen
möchte das so und dann einfach ein
bisschen zucker und ob geben und das war
es eigentlich mit unserem toppen können
später auch noch andere sachen dazu und
schoko drops streusel
soße oder irgendwelche krems ich kann
eigentlich eine sonntag geben also die
basis ist er wirklich der ta cco die
frucht und die leckerste cheesecake
gelungen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich erfülle mir jetzt die creme noch in
einen spritzbeutel damit es einfacher
ist und auch schicker aussieht denn ich
nehme sterne vorne dran die 201 aus dem
stoff kann ich euch gerne verlinken und
da könnte hier vorne einfach denn die
spitze abschneiden wenn die tülle
dadurch schieben und dann kommt
eigentlich nur noch die c klasse in die
tacos die sind natürlich jetzt abgekühlt
und die erdbeeren und top und halt alle
toppings die ihr möchtet und man sollte
die schon schnell servieren also man
sollte jetzt nicht irgendwie am vortag
vorbereiten oder so ihr müsst jetzt
durch die feuchtigkeit der tränenreichen
dita kuster irgendwann durch also eine
gute halbe steuer könnte das nicht
vorbereiten aber dann solltet ihr die
auch wirklich direkt servieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
strawberry cheesecake tacos ich bin
begeistert ich bin begeistert was
lustiges diese taktik ist aber herzhaft
mag ja erzählen dubai waren habe ich
tacos mit knochenmark gegessen und
seitdem wurden so schlecht bin ich am
tag kurz gedacht habt aber jetzt bin ich
wieder voll haben sagte
das ist eine käsecreme vom browser
eigentlich so zur paar dunkler verhilft
das eine ist mit diesen karamell keksen
gemacht worden die welt und das andere
mit butter keksen oder
es kribbelt überall
ich gebe
15 von 10 möglichen punkten leiter
e-commerce aussichten dachdämmung
natürlich aus wie brot hier müsse man
das ist
sehr sehr wortgewandt sieht heftig aus
leute
so lecker ich bin so begeistert wie soll
ich den geschmack beschreiben ein
clicker wirke aber das also guck mal
angewandt ich hab mal ordentlich
gegessen ich kann das gerade muss man
der seite ist nicht von oben an der
seite das ist die kunst komm ich zeig
dir und perfekt schlusskurve was neues
ist also in dieses tortilla ist ja noch
gar nicht nicht wie lange ich das hier
schon sarah stündchen und halbe alter
schon es ist noch nichts durchgereicht
also kann man so nicht stehen lassen
jetzt kann sagen kannst dich stehen
lassen handgemacht nachhaltig geld macht
hier eine die werden euch lieben weil
das gesetz muss nun ja vielleicht hitze
der sommertrend
2022 geblieben vom man weiß ja nie ganz
viel spaß zum nachmachen abonniert doch
das ist ja abonniert oder abonniert
channel und schreiben sie einen
kommentar das rezept findet und dann
sehen wir uns auch
[Musik]
[Applaus]